here's a question we should all be
asking
what went wrong not just with the
pandemic
but with our civic life what brought us
to this polarized rancorous political
moment
in recent decades the divide between
winners and losers
has been deepening poisoning our
politics
setting us apart this divide
is partly about inequality but it's
also about the attitudes toward winning
and losing
that have come with it those who landed
on top
came to believe that their success was
their own
doing a measure of their merit
and that those who lost out had no one
to blame
but themselves this way of thinking
about success
arises from a seemingly attractive
principle
if everyone has an equal chance the
winners
deserve their winnings this is the heart
of the meritocratic ideal
in practice of course we fall far short
not everybody has an equal chance to
rise
children born to poor families tend to
stay poor
when they grow up affluent parents
are able to pass their advantages onto
their kids
at ivy league universities for example
there are more students from the top one
percent
than from the entire bottom half of the
country
combined but the problem isn't
only that we fail to live up to the
meritocratic principles
we proclaim the ideal itself
is flawed it has a dark side
meritocracy is corrosive of the common
good
it leads to hubris among the winners
and humiliation among those who lose out
it encourages the successful to inhale
too deeply of their success to forget
the luck and good fortune that help them
on their way
and it leads them to look down on those
less fortunate less credentialed than
themselves
this matters for politics
one of the most potent sources of the
populist backlash
is the sense among many working people
that elites look down on them
it's a legitimate complaint even
as globalization brought deepening
inequality
and stagnant wages its proponents
offered workers some bracing advice
if you want to compete and win in the
global economy
go to college what you earn
depends on what you learn you can make
it if you try
these elites missed the insult
implicit in this advice
if you don't go to college if you don't
flourish
in the new economy your failure
is your fault that's the implication
it's no wonder many working people
turned against
meritocratic elites so what should we do
we need to rethink three aspects of our
civic life
the role of college the dignity of work
and the meaning of success
we should begin by rethinking the role
of universities
as arbiters of opportunity
for those of us who spend our days in
the company
of the credentialed it's easy to forget
a simple fact most people don't have
a four-year college degree in fact
nearly two-thirds of americans don't
so it is folly to create an economy
that makes a university diploma a
necessary condition
of dignified work and a decent life
encouraging people to go to college is a
good thing
broadening access for those who can't
afford it is even better
but this is not a solution to inequality
we should focus less on arming people
for meritocratic combat and focus
more on making life better for people
who lack a diploma
but who make essential contributions
to our society we should renew the
dignity of work
and place it at the center of our
politics
we should remember that work is not only
about making a living
it's also about contributing to the
common good
and winning recognition for doing so
robert f kennedy put it well half a
century ago
fellowship community shared patriotism
these essential values do not come
from just buying and consuming goods
together
they come from dignified employment at
decent pay
the kind of employment that enables us
to say
i helped to build this country i am a
participant
in its great public ventures
this civic sentiment is largely missing
from our public life today
we often assume that the money people
make
is the measure of their contribution to
the common good
but this is a mistake martin luther king
jr
explained why reflecting on a strike
by sanitation workers in memphis
tennessee
shortly before he was assassinated king
said
the person who picks up our garbage is
in the final analysis as significant
as the physician for if he doesn't do
his job
diseases are rampant all
labor has dignity
today's pandemic makes this clear
it reveals how deeply we rely
on workers we often overlook
delivery workers maintenance workers
grocery store clerks warehouse workers
truckers nurse assistants
child care workers home health care
providers
these are not the best paid or most
honored workers but now
we see them as essential workers
this is a moment for a public debate
about how to bring their pay and
recognition
into better alignment with the
importance
of their work it is also time
for a moral even spiritual turning
questioning our meritocratic hubris
do i morally deserve the talents that
enable me to flourish
is it my doing that i live in a society
that
prizes the talents i happen to have
or is that my good luck insisting that
my success
is my do makes it hard to see myself
in other people's shoes appreciating the
role of luck in life
can prompt a certain humility there but
for the accident of birth
or the grace of god or the mystery of
fate
go i this spirit of humility
is the civic virtue we need now
it's the beginning of a way back from
the harsh
ethic of success that drives us apart
it points us beyond the tyranny of merit
to a less rancorous more generous
public life